uh there was a bet between um
mitchell kaku and somebody else uh about
john horgan john horgan about uh
uh by the way made me discover a cool
website longbets.com
org yeah yeah it's cool it's cool that
you can make a bet with people
uh and then check in 20 years later
that's i really love it there's a lot of
interesting bets on there yeah i would
love to participate but it's interesting
to see you know tom flies yeah
and you make a bet about what's going to
happen 20 years you don't realize 20
years just goes like this yeah yeah and
then and then you get to face oh and you
get to wonder
like
what
was that person what was i thinking that
person 20 years ago was almost like a
different person what was i thinking
back then to think that
is interesting but so let me ask you
this on record
uh you know 20 years from now or some
number of years from now do you think
there will be a nobel prize given for
something directly connected to a first
broadly theory of everything
and second
of course uh one of the possibilities
one of them uh string theory
um
strength
definitely not that uh things have gone
yeah
so fine if you were giving financial
advice you would say not to bet on no do
not
i actually suspect if you ask strength
here as that question these guys you're
going to get a few of them saying i mean
if you'd asked them that question 20
years ago again when
kaku was making this better whatever i
think some some of them would have taken
you up on it but um and certainly back
in 1984 a bunch of them would have said
oh sure yeah but now i get the
impression that
they've they've even they realized that
things are not looking good for that
particular idea again it depends what
you mean by string theory whether
maybe the term will evolve to mean
something else which which will work out
but
i don't know i don't think that's not
going to
likely to work out whether um something
else i mean i i still think it's
relatively unlikely that you'll have any
really successful theory everything and
and the main problem is is just the um
it's become so difficult to do
experiments at higher energy that we've
really lost this ability to kind of get
unexpected input from
from experiment and and you can you know
while it's maybe hard to figure out what
people's thinking is going to be 20
years from now looking at um
you know energy particle energy
colliders and their technology it's
actually pretty easy to make a pretty
accurate guess what it's going to look
what
except what you're going to be doing 20
years from now and um
i think actually
i would actually claim that
it's pretty clear what where you're
going to be 20 years from now and what
it's going to be is you're going to have
the um
you're going to have the the lhc you're
going to have a lot more data an order
of magnitude or more
or more
data from the lhc but at the same energy
you're not going gonna you're not gonna
see a higher energy um
accelerator operating successfully in
the um in the next 20 years and like um
maybe machine learning or great sort of
data science methodologies that process
that data will not reveal any
major
uh like shifts in our understanding of
the underlying physics you think i don't
think so i mean i think that that that
feel that my understanding is that they
they're starting to make a great use of
those techniques but but it seems to
look like it it will help them solve
certain technical problems and be able
to do things somewhat better but not
completely change
the way they're looking at things
you